byron york is chief political
correspondent the washington examiner
tom Fitton is president of judicial
watch they join us both tonight Tom
first to you you read these questions
your reaction was what well you have to
wonder what molar is up to here is he
acting as a special counsel you read
these questions you might be curious as
to the answers if you were a journalist
or a politician trying to attack Donald
Trump for a prosecutor be putting out
questions like this and the demand the
time of the President of the United
States is an abuse of his power and
Muller is just wandering around bumping
into walls investigatively speaking
there's not much here in the way of
Russia collusion asking his opinions and
questions about his tweets to me is a
waste of time in the president's time
and I can't imagine a judge is going to
allow him to force the president to have
to answer many of these questions since
they're so off-kilter from any
legitimate legal analysis or legal
prosecution that he might be whether
profusing at the very least owned on
lawyers like me looking at this by order
they suggested direction what do they
tell us assuming they're real about the
direction of this investigation first of
all it's not just a group of
40-something questions it's it's a
potentially unlimited number of
questions when they say well when did
you first find out about that June 2016
meeting in Trump Tower doesn't that
naturally lead to who told you what did
they say the purpose was how many people
were involved did they tell you what
happened I mean each question is which
seems kind of benign and open-ended can
lead to all sorts of additional
questions but I think what you were
getting at in your introduction is the
point that we've seen a lot which is
asking Trump's motivations for the
perfectly normal actions of a president
we've seen that in other court cases
from the travel ban to Dhaka to other
other things in which the the legitimate
exercise of presidential power is
questioned because the president
apparently had some sort of unacceptable
motive and that's what's involved
that's a theological debate not a
political policy debate are you
pure-hearted that's not really the
concern of federal prosecutors right
well that's because everybody knows that
he had the power to to fire the
the FBI or he is the power to to rake
his attorney general over the coals
whether or not that's a good idea is
completely separate the question here
with with Comey seems to be what was
your state of mind when you're doing
that if you did that with a pure
intention okay by me but if you did it
with a bad intention you could be indeed
Martin Luther for a secular government
to pursue that line of questioning so
even asking about what you think of my
appointment what was your reaction to my
appointment he's asking about himself
this is like a Playboy questionnaire
yeah what are your greatest strengths
what are your turn-off but does it tell
us I mean I think the key question is is
this investigation moving in the
direction from which it started which is
an investigation into collusion
purportedly with the Russian government
during the campaign do you get that
sense from these questions I just see
this as the kind of the fantasy list of
fusion GPS Adam Schiff type questions
they're pushing that narrative that's
been out there and you look at this and
you got to wonder forget about the FISA
Court misusing this dossier or being led
to misuse this dossier it looks to me
like Muller is using this dossier as the
basis for a lot of these vague questions
on Russia his business dealings in
Russia and just taking this I think that
this anti-trump media narrative and
bringing it into the prosecutorial
function of the Justice Department it's
a real abuse and rod Rosenstein needs to
be held accountable for unleashing this
on the American people the presidency
and the Justice Department are just see
how it's made the country better is it I
haven't checked Byron you're very
current with the law is it a crime to
say sympathetic things toward Russia as
far as I know absolutely not
so the this list of questions if you
know I have to say I completely lost my
train of thought on this does it seem
like this is moving however toward what
we were promised at the outset which is
an examination of whether Russia played
a significant role in our watch the
thing to remember about the
is there's not a whole lot new in these
questions when you look at some of the
areas Michael Flynn commis sessions and
collusion it doesn't indicate that that
Muller has come up with some completely
new area of inquiry that we didn't know
about before actually there is this is
pretty much what we have been talking
about for the last year or so so from
that point it seems to me that the Trump
people should be somewhat relieved in
the sense that we seem to know
everything Joe segment I mean that's
I've totally lost interest you know what
I mean like Carter page was not
subverting democracy I just don't you
know you haven't convinced me what the
House Intelligence Committee found the
other day that there was no evidence of
collusion and there's nothing in this
list of questions to suggest that Muller
has info that the house itself is
covering up for Vladimir Putin okay just
so you know gentlemen thank you well
that